What is taqiyya? It's a doctrine that
tells Muslims you can dissemble your
true intentions. Muhammad himself said
war is deceit. Smile to the face of the
infidel while your heart curses them.
There's another even deeper doctrine
which I translate as
Schools across the north of England are
now being told you can't draw Jesus.
>> The more liberal the culture becomes the
more it actually is repulsive to
Muslims. The Western mind seems to think
they're going to like us. To the Muslim
mind that just breeds more and more
contempt. [music]
>> Look how weak they are. All I have to
look at is just demographics. The
official numbers they give the UK
[music] at 8 or 9% which means about 15
20% What do you do when England is 50%
Muslim? Between around the year 1000 and
1500 80 million Hindus were slaughtered.
They're aggressive and bold and they
want their way and if you protest well
you're an evil Islamophobe and you're
going to jail. I just came across a
Winston Churchill quote. You won't fight
now when you actually have a good chance
and you may even be able to win without
even much bloodshed. The time will come
when you will have to.
I give you a a jar of candies. There's a
hundred. Ten of these are poisoned. Now
here, go give it to your kids. The
burden of proof has to be on you not me
and I'm sorry [music] but you're part of
a religion that makes it like that.
Raymond Ibrahim, welcome to the show.
Thank you. Happy to be with you. Happy
to have you here. Um tell me a little
bit I want to I'm we're going to cover a
lot in Islam. In fact before I go into
I'm going to ask you about Iran but I
want to know a little bit about your
background and what you write about and
and research.
>> [snorts and clears throat]
>> All right. So my background is
we have to start very personal
apparently. We have to be personal my so
we can understand. I come from an my
family's from Egypt. They're the Copts,
Coptic Christians. They left Egypt. I
was born in the United States. Um they
left in [snorts] late 60s. I was born
early 70s. And anyway so I tell you that
because obviously I had an interest in
that world, Christians and Muslims and
and what happens there in that nexus.
And I also heard stories from my family,
etc. And then fast forward, I majored in
history. Um yeah, we were talking about
Fresno State.
BA and MA and uh maybe you know Victor
Davis Hanson of course was um my
professor at the time. So that was that
was a fun time.
>> [clears throat]
>> And uh
I my master's thesis actually with him.
He was the the department chair. Um was
about the first battle between Muslims
and Christians. So I was very much
interested in that and I had also been
studying the various languages, Greek,
Arabic. Um and then 9/11 happened and um
I decided to continue uh my studies and
I went to Georgetown University, which
at the time was one of the most um
prestigious universities for that field,
Islam, Middle East.
Um I went there. I I I I didn't like it.
I got great I got all A's, but
I was still young and naive. I didn't
understand about political correctness
and you know the the academic narrative
and how they were they were bent on
showing Islam's good and uh I was just
treating things objectively.
But um so I didn't like it. I was doing
well, but then I got a job with the
Library of Congress
dealing again with Middle Eastern Arabic
books and uh that field. And that was an
amazing job.
And before long it became a full-time
job. It was 40 hour
week.
And before long I also came across
writings in Arabic that were written by
Osama bin Laden and Ayman al-Zawahiri,
al-Qaeda.
And this was still when al-Qaeda was big
news. I found these in 2004. So just a
few years after 2001. And what was
interesting about these writings in
Arabic is they were completely different
than what al-Qaeda had been sending
messages to the West saying. So
previously al-Qaeda's message uh was we
attacked you because you attacked us
first. It's all about reciprocal
treatment. You've done this, that, and
the other thing. Israel, you and Israel
are are torturing everyone, uh
colonialism, you know, the Crusades,
what you people have done to us. So the
whole narrative was this big long
grievance mantra, okay? Even at one
point, he was complaining that the US
didn't sign on to the Kyoto Protocol,
believe it or not, about the
environment. Yeah. Specific. Yeah, he
actually mentioned that.
Um so, that that those were the messages
that were being disseminated to the
West, and the media Western media was
helping because they want to show you
what the other side is saying.
What I came across in Arabic, though,
said the exact opposite. It sounded more
like ISIS.
Because now he's talking to fellow
Muslims in Arabic, not thinking no one
infidel is going to be privy to this
information, and it was basically, yeah,
we have to hate and war against them cuz
they're infidels. It has nothing to do
with what they do, whether they're good
or kind to us or bad or evil, we have to
subjugate them.
So, Can you do me a favor? If you get
value from these conversations, hit
subscribe. I want to on that point, cuz
I I spoke last week at the European
Parliament about the Islamification of
Europe, and an Imam was there sort of
giving the other side, and he said, "No,
no, what infidels really means, and I'm
sure you know where this is going, is is
just
sort of non-believers, but even atheists
are fine as well. So, it's not actually
Christians and Jews and so on." I I
imagine you'd dispute that. Yeah, well
well, we we can definitely get into the
the linguistic aspect, and I I would
like to say that something about that,
but
if I finish the story, I think it'll be
good because so then when when I wrote
that, so I got a book deal of the Arabic
thing cuz I wanted to show
what Al-Qaeda had been saying to Muslims
versus what they said to non-Muslims,
and it came out in my first book, The
Al-Qaeda Reader, which was finally
published in 2007.
>> [snorts]
>> And um
So, anyway, that that
that in very early on initially struck
me as an a perfect example. I came from,
again, a back academic background
studying history, so I was very much
interested in jihad and crusades, but
when I came across the Al-Qaeda thing, I
believed originally what they were
saying, which is, "Oh, we're doing this
because you've done that." So, when I
read in Arabic what they were really
saying and how they were referencing
history to solidify their point and
talking about, "Yes, you know, we are
the nation of the jihad, etc., etc." I
thought that that has stayed with me
really since from then to now. And so,
one of my writing missions is just to
show the continuity, the true
continuity,
between Islamic hostility for the West,
past and present. And also all the many
lies that permeated past and present
because we have the same examples of
deception and lies and and all that sort
of thing going on. As far as infidel,
uh it's funny because they they come up
with all these apologetics and I think
what he's trying to tell you is so the
word infidel, well, that's that's an
English word. It's not even necessarily
a good translation. I use it often. The
word is kafir in Arabic. And it's true.
So, so a kafir is a non-Muslim. You can
translate it as a non-Muslim, but that's
their way of trying to
make it hygienic because
what it is is is a non-Muslim, but the
word is loaded with so many pejoratives
and evil connotations. Okay? So, by
default, to be a non-Muslim based on
this word is to be an enemy.
Okay? So, and maybe the other things
that they they play with is they'll call
Christians and Jews people of the book.
That's what he was angling at. Right.
Ahl al-Kitab, which is So, if you're Ahl
al-Kitab, a people of the book, yes, you
are technically better to be treated
better than the kafir, but it's not a
whole lot better. The kafir is you
submit, convert to Islam, or die. That's
it. The Christian and the Jew is submit,
become Muslim, or fine, keep your
religion, pay tribute, and be a
second-class citizen. And you know, or
or more like a third-class citizen if
you really understand it. So, it's
marginally better, but
but the the war is to be waged on both
until they submit one way or the other.
The The difference is the Christian and
Jew has the right to maintain their
faith, but they are suppressed subjects.
Quran 9:29 is the key one which says
fight the people of the book until they
until they pay tribute and feel
themselves humbled. So, it's not just
about taking money from them. You have
to make sure that in the social order
that they are suppressed. And one of the
reasons for that is in the hopes that
eventually they convert. And they did.
That is actually the history of how
Islam spread. It would conquer regions,
let's say Egypt, my ancestral homeland,
or Syria. The vast majority of the
people there were actually Christians,
the overwhelming majority, with also a
lot of uh Jews in Alexandria.
And so, they had the right to pay
tribute. But before long, people are
have no money. It's an It's a demanding
amount of uh you know uh tribute that
they want. And people get tired of being
social outcast. They They can't get
jobs. They are despised. They can't you
know So, they become Muslims. That's the
true story of the spread of Islam. And
it's actually understood that this jizya
tax, based on that Quran, is on the one
hand to show some leniency, on the other
hand it's kind of a
we get money out of you, and then
eventually you become a Muslim. I So, I
didn't actually realize it worked that
way. I thought what was happening was,
looking at the Middle East, and I've got
a you know, fleeting knowledge of it,
that that that they would come in taking
over, killing the non-believers, and and
that's how Islam spread. But you're
saying actually people would just
converting because it was so it was so
difficult not to. Yeah, there was a lot
of social So, yeah, if you're not a if
you were a Christian or Jew, you were
you were technically given the object.
Now, I'm giving you the actual law, the
way it's understood. I'm sure
historically there were all sorts of
aberrations where they didn't even give
the Christians or Jews, and they killed
them outright. And there were even times
when they got So, for example, the
Hindus,
they're not people of book. So,
theoretically when the massive jihad
began on them, it's supposedly between
um around the year 1000 and 1500, 80
million Hindus were slaughtered, okay,
during this period. And technically they
were not supposed to give them the the
the opportunity to pay tribute and keep
their religion. But if eventually it got
so bad that they figured, "You know
what? Why don't we just make money out
of this? What's another dead Hindu?"
So, they did give them that status that
they could pay and keep the religion.
So, my point is there's always some
elasticity to these rules depending on
on how they work. But um
but and there was even a time when uh
very early on where a lot of the subject
peoples wanted to convert because of the
social pressures and the and the
financial pressures, but the the caliphs
wouldn't let them. Because once you
convert, that's that's uh their income
drops cuz they don't get that extra tax.
So, it was actually more advantageous
for the caliphs to have their subject
people not be Muslim. That was a whole
controversy, but eventually it it went
away. But gradually these these
countries did become
Muslim. Some sometimes some of them was
what in the last few hundred years and
sometimes in the last like 50, 60 years,
right? Iran, Afghanistan, you see those
pictures don't you of you know, people
women in dresses and things. Um what are
what are the most recent ones? Would
that be Iran and and Most recent nations
that have become Muslim? Yeah. No, the
UK, France.
>> [laughter]
>> Oh, you're you're asking more and more
Yeah, well, we'll get into that. That's
that's the most recent I suppose.
>> Yeah. And what is it it's a fact, isn't
it? I mean, was it the UAE that recently
banned its students from doing exchange
in the UK because of radicalization?
Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. Well, well, that's the
thing. Places like in Egypt and Saudi
Arabia, the Muslim Brotherhood is
banned. The Muslim Brotherhood was born
in Egypt. So, if anything, it has a lot
of sympathizers there, but it's banned
and yet in the West, it's not often.
Why?
>> [laughter]
>> You tell me.
Uh because even at that point, you can't
even be accused of Islamophobia because
Muslims are banning them. It's a
terrorist organization, okay? Whether it
has an Islamic veneer or it's
substantially Islamic, those Muslims are
banning it and that doesn't make them
Islamophobes. So I don't know why the
West has any compunction about banning a
terrorist organization. What's the best
argument you can give that that for a
the left what do we call it steel man or
strong manning? A straw man argument?
>> Like the opposite like building up the
best possible
>> Oh.
>> other side
>> Yeah.
>> for a lefty who would be saying now no
that's not going to happen. What
happened in Iran, Afghanistan, Lebanon
>> Right.
>> Egypt won't happen here.
>> It's not going to happen here. Yeah,
what's the best argument for them? For
them in other words I was one of them.
If you were one of them what would you
say? Hang on it's not going to happen in
Britain. Here's why. Okay. So you're
asking me to think like I'm insane.
>> Yes.
>> And come up with a very strong argument.
I see what you're saying. Yeah, or what
would they say at least even
>> I'm trying to think. Yeah, that's a good
question. I've never put my mind into
theirs. That's a scary thought. But
what they would say that it's So in
other words how do would they
rationalize that? Yeah, the current
situation is not so bad. This isn't
going to become Londonistan or a new
caliphate.
>> Yeah.
I think it would be because of a lot of
it has to do with naivete and a little
bit of cultural arrogance. They're just
probably convinced that in due time all
the Muslims that come here will just
assimilate and secularize because you
know everyone knows the truth is
secularization and that's the objective
happy life and you know they can only do
this draconian sharia so much and I'm
sure they'll all eventually one way or
the other just assimilate. But it's
really the opposite because if anything
you look at if you [snorts] look at who
gets radicalized it's the it's the later
generations the second and third
generations. Mhm. And I have I have a
deep theory about that. It's a symbiotic
relationship actually that that Western
liberals and the more liberal the
culture becomes the more it actually is
repulsive to Muslims and it pushes them
back on their conservative ways because
they see So when they see for example in
the UK or wherever
Western people English people
appeasing them
um, know covering up their crosses so
they don't offend them, inviting them to
come and and and and, you know, proclaim
Quran truths in the church and all that.
The Western mind seems to think, "See,
they're going to like us cuz we're
showing them up." To the Muslim mind,
that that just breeds more and more and
more contempt and really reaffirms that,
"Yeah, we have the truth. See, even they
know it."
>> Look how weak they are.
>> Yeah. So,
um, that's why I think there's that
that's it and and and there's the
opposite of that, actually. If you go
back to the colonial era when the West
was unabashedly
um, proud of its ways and and it went
into the Islamic world and into India
and Africa
and it didn't uh, as they as they say,
pussyfoot around, you know, it was very
objective and proud of its uh, strength.
Well, what did the Muslims do? Did they
scream jihad? Actually, by and large,
they all tried to emulate it.
And they all shaved their beard and put
on Western dress and women were not
wearing the hijab and they were in
dress, high heels. And even the number
one country um, or or empire, the
Ottoman Empire, which at once was the
greatest scourge of Europe from a
jihadist mentality, they were the first
ones to get rid of all that and totally
become Westernized under Ataturk. They
even got rid of the Arabic script and
adopted the Roman alphabet for the
Turkish language. Um, so
that's what I mean by a symbiotic
relationship in as much as the West
exudes power and confidence, that
actually attracts Muslims and makes them
want to emulate and assimilate. In as
much as it exudes weakness and uh, just
this this pathetic kind of culture like
uh,
that draws them back and repulses them
and makes them want to want to conquer
them. You know, it's a it's almost like
the bully I use I call it the yard the
schoolyard bully mentality. If you are
just weak and kind of like pathetic, he
he starts off testing you how far I can
go with you, you know, and and the more
you give in, the more aggressive he
becomes, right? But if you give him a
swift punch in the nose, before you know
you know it, he respects and becomes
your best friend. Yeah. Okay, so I think
that's that very much governs how
Muslims see the West. It's It's It's
when you put it that way, it seems so
obvious that that is basic human
psychology. And yet this leftist
narrative persists. We just had as as
you'll probably be aware, I mean firstly
we had with the education what what
you're talking about. Literally schools,
I think across the north of England at
the moment, they might spread further
south,
are now being told you can't draw Jesus.
I've heard Jesus can't be drawn by
Muslims.
Um we also had got a Gorton and Denton
in the in the north of England, they
just lost it was one one of the first
big
uh you know um
uh votes that was that was really lost
based on sectarian voting. Uh the Greens
won. And a lot of the left are now
saying, "Ha, you guys thought that
Muslims were socially conservative, but
they've just voted for a gay Jew in
charge of the Greens, and I've never
heard them mention the environment. The
Greens don't talk about the environment,
even though they're supposed to be the
Greens." Mhm. What would you What would
your rebuttal be to those people?
That the Muslims see them all as useful
idiots. Mhm. And I'll give you a perfect
example in Michigan, Hamtramck, I think
it's pronounced, it's a
somewhere in Michigan, it's a small
smaller city,
which has a large Muslim population. And
you know, when it was a small Muslim
population, who welcomed them in and who
tried to buttress them and support them
was the extreme left, okay?
And the more woke, the more they helped
them, okay?
And before long it became, I don't know
if the city's Muslim majority, but once
the city council became Muslim majority,
the first thing they did is cancel gay
pride, okay? And the left, the people
who had supported them just freaked out
and said, "Well, we helped you, we
thought this and that." But that's a
perfect example of, you know, the
Muslims will adroitly ride the wave that
helps them, even if it is with leftists,
Jews, gays, whatever, but when the time
comes and they
and this has an old lineage in the
Islamic mentality. Even Muhammad himself
would do that sort of thing.
When the time comes then, you know, the
the mask comes off as it were. I think
it's very possible that probably not the
next election but the one after that. So
we're talking about seven or eight years
in the UK now that the Greens as a kind
of Islamo woke alliance will will get in
charge.
How how will that look in the first few
months and years?
Well, I see things differently. I really
have a I don't I think the problem is
too many people are myopic and they just
really look at the current news and
what's being said today and and but I
like to stand back
>> [clears throat]
>> and maybe it's with my background in
history and kind of look at the long
picture.
And all I see is just a slow degrade,
okay,
in the in the UK but just the West in
general. And and all I have to look at
is just demographics. That's it, okay?
If I look and you know, the official
numbers they gave, let's say, the UK. I
think it the official is what? Eight or
nine percent?
>> Yeah, but it's probably higher than
that.
>> which means about 15, 20%? I think so.
>> Yeah, I think so, too, okay?
>> The last census was five years ago.
We've had millions of people come in
since then. Right. So it's already
significantly higher. The you know, just
closing the border or or preventing
illegals from coming in seems to be this
massive, you know, hard thing to do even
in the in the US as we see with the
whole ICE thing and and the US is a more
cowboy society. You'd think it wouldn't
be a big deal because they're trying to
round up people who don't belong here
and most of them are criminals and you
can see all the meltdowns. So can you
imagine something like that happening
here in the UK? I find that very
difficult to conceive. So even if but
even if the you could slow down the
immigration, the fact that they're you
know, they're reproducing much much
faster. So it's impossible at this
point. Every decade, every
and I already saw, for example, a Pew
study said in Germany
something like in 20 years it's going to
be I don't know 25% Muslim.
And and then what? And then how about in
30 years? So in in other words, just the
status quo with nothing crazy happening
and
people and politicians bickering over
the little tiny minutia that never
matters, okay? And saying we're going to
do this, we're going to do that, or none
of this. And and time progresses,
numbers are going to keep growing and
keep growing and keep growing. And then
what do you do when England is 50%
Muslim? At that point,
you know, or I mean 30%. What do you do
at that point? And they're
aggressive and they're bold and they
want their way and then and the dumb
left is supporting them and you and
they're in the and they're in the
government and if you protest, well,
you're an evil Islamophobe and you're
going to jail, okay? So, that's what I
foresee coming and it's because I I just
came across a Winston Churchill quote,
which I'll paraphrase and he said it I
think before
in the context of World War II,
about I think at the time, let's say
Britain's reluctance to enter the war.
And he basically the quote is, "If you
don't fight now when, you know, you
actually have a good chance and you may
even be able to win without even much
bloodshed, the time will come when you
will have to fight and you will have all
the odds against you and you'll probably
lose." So, I think that's um
you know, people are just putting their
hope in this or that politician, party.
I don't see any of them being able to do
to undo what's been done, which is just
It's one thing to stop immigration, but
like I said, the damage is done. You can
stop it and the they're here.
>> [laughter]
>> Now, okay? And reverse migration to me
sounds like a pipe dream. I don't think
it's possible. Of course, anyone can do
it. And but
knowing what I know about the psychology
of Western people, it would be would be
so it seemed as so humanitarian. So,
they won't do it. It will never happen.
will never do it. And so, the end result
will be
year after year, decade after decade,
look for Muslim numbers to grow and with
its influence and power and
assertiveness. And we'll become a Muslim
country eventually. Yeah. Yeah.
Peter Boghossian is a mutual friend of
ours and he
often says
uh I think no one knows if he's saying
this facetiously. I don't think even he
knows. But he says it's time to actually
make a deal with the Muslims and and
just give up Europe basically or at
least give up the UK. What do you make
of of that and and what's the
alternative?
Yeah, I'm hoping he's he's asked He's
said that to me on on camera multiple
times and I'm assuming he's being
facetious because I I don't think they
have to do that right now because they
can just Why make a deal? Well, just
continue sinking slowly. At least you
have these few years where you can
imagine yourself as being in authority.
So, what's the hurry to make a deal? And
then later on you can. So, I don't think
I don't think they need to make a deal
at this point. You can just let things
happen organically. Just let them take
over through numbers and then eventually
you'll you'll get it in line one way or
the other. So, at least you have a few
years before that. The problem is if you
were to leave, the whole of Europe's
gone. And and I always held out this
thought of okay, let's say it got worst
worst case scenario, somewhere like
Texas, Arizona. You mentioned the sort
of cowboy cavalier attitude.
But that that doesn't seem to be Are
they going to hold up? Is there going to
be anywhere? That's the thing. That's
you know, so
the Texas that shocked me because in
America Texas is kind of like that's the
most redneck, you know, no nonsense. We
don't play around. Everyone's got their
cowboy hat and gun.
And then you turn around and find out
it's it's becoming so Islam It's like
one of the most Islamized states in
America. I don't know. The numbers that
I hear I haven't really confirmed them
with how many mosques are being built,
you know, rapidly and
like Islamization going on. It's just
amazing if that state is going through
that, okay? And the same thing like I
told you with the immigration and ICE.
They're just enforcing a law that every
country has, which is you can't break in
here and live and and we're going after
the criminals who already engaged in
crime. And just look at the meltdown
that the general public is having. And
so that's what I mean. Ultimately, all
of these issues
you have to understand all these
problems are self-made. None of these
are from the Muslims themselves. The
Muslims are weak at this point of time.
I write about history. I talk about when
Muslims invaded and conquered and the
people of Europe or wherever fought back
and sometimes they were they were
conquered, sometimes they weren't and it
was a bloodbath either way.
Right now, Islam is completely weak
compared to let's say Europe or America.
So that's why when a lot of people
complain say Muslims are invading the
UK. No, they're not. They're being
invited into the UK. Let's be serious.
You can stop them if you wanted to
easily. So I think the problem is all
these um
It's really an intellectual or
epistemological problem where you know,
the society has created all these
barriers that have paralyzed it that it
can't act anymore because something
about human rights or something about my
multiculturalism, you know, these things
have have so dominated the way people
think that they can't just engage in
common sense or or or or implement
policy non-suicidal policies that are
meant to preserve the host society. But
the power is there. You know, it could
be done. That's why I say
yeah, the the UK could easily get rid of
the Muslim problem if it wanted to. It
could engage in reverse immigration. It
could do all sorts of things like take
away all the economic boons that are
given, which will make Muslims kind of
be like, well, why am I out here in the
cold getting nothing. Maybe I'll leave.
So there's so much I can be done. The
question is
uh
Western people have been so
I don't know what's the best word here,
but just um Castrated.
Yeah, good one. I was going to say
emasculated. So, emasculated and
castrated that they just simply can't do
what needs doing. They don't have the
stomach for it because they have to be
the good guy, you know, I
I'm the tolerant, enlightened,
open-minded progressive. Yeah. And
that's what's destroying and going to
kill them. It's not the Muslims. The
Muslims are a byproduct. I don't see
them as a inherent issue. It's a
byproduct. It could be nipped in the bud
quickly. But, look at a country like
Hungary and Poland. They don't have this
problem. Are they more powerful than the
UK and Germany? I don't think so. All
they did is put up a fence and said,
"No. No, thanks.
We're good." So, maybe those are the
countries that Yeah, that will that will
that will be the remainder of the West.
Bloody hell. It's It's so crazy all of
this. I I was recently It's interesting
what you're saying about the mentality
cuz I was recently in Israel and I went
into the West Bank and all of these
places and I met a lot of the Muslim
Israelis there. And there's something
really struck me was that they're
they're very submissive.
And that was not what I've been used to
in the Muslim community in the UK.
Obviously, there's all different kinds
of people. I've met some wonderful
Muslim people and some not so nice and
so on. But, they were very They were
sort of scared a little bit. I would ask
them things on camera and they were a
little bit scared. Didn't want to say
what they Those kinds of things because
I think they on you know, sometimes not
in a good way or sometimes in a good
way. They're under the you know, under
the thumb of of the Israeli government
there.
And it's something that it really struck
me cuz in the West that is not how you
see Islam. Mhm. It made me think, okay,
so if you if you did have
You don't want an authoritarian regime,
but a bit more authority. Yeah, yeah,
that goes back to sort of what I was
saying about the bully mentality, you
know, if if you're strong and
authoritative, then yeah, they become
meek,
docile, and responsive. If you're like,
"Oh, yeah, yeah, whatever you guys want.
I'll do anything for you." then they
become aggressive and violent. It's It's
It is human nature, you know, but it's
It's especially has a long history
amongst Muslim peoples. Mhm. What do you
think of I mean the individual Muslims
coming here? As you say, a lot of them
just want economic security and a better
prosperity and all those things. A lot
of them are good, nice people.
Presumably they most individuals who
come here don't want to be under some
kind of regime as they would be in Iran.
Presumably, yeah. But then is that the
is that the the hard thing? But but if
lots of them come at once, that's just
the inevitable and an inevitability.
Yeah, because of the and that's one of
the problems when they come in huge
numbers they they they don't
[clears throat] assimilate because they
just stay amongst each other. That's why
you have here in this country, as I
understand it, Muslims who been living
here for decades don't speak a word of
English.
>> Yeah. Okay? Because they become
ghettoized, they live in their own
enclaves, and then guess what? Well,
Islamic culture prevails cuz that's what
they know. And
so they never have a chance to
assimilate. So, if anything, that's one
more reason not to have so many because
and we've seen this before in other
contexts and countries and nations. When
you bring small amounts, then they can
assimilate quickly because they they
have to be they're they're amongst the
whole society. But in this case,
but again, you also have to be cognizant
of this I find this generational thing
interesting. It's not the ones who, you
know, who came 20 years ago first
generation and then he freaked out and
said I'm going to become a radical. It's
it's the one that was born here or or
second generation or you know, like a a
grandkid who was born here. He's the one
that turns to Islam. And I think it goes
back to what I was saying, which is this
sort of
you know, repulsive
repulse by Western liberal culture.
Um again, this is the same idea we're
talking about the the bully, you know?
Yeah, yeah. It's it it doesn't the more
you
This is the kind of culture where the
more you appease and cajole and and try
to give them what they want, the they
don't reciprocate and say, "Oh, what a
gentleman. Let me also be a gentleman."
No, it's seen like, "Oh, he's weak.
That's why he's doing that because I'm
stronger." And then it gives them
confidence and then they want more.
So, that's why I think those general
younger guys
then fall back to their heritage because
they find that that's the best way to
respond to Western weakness. What is
taqiyya?
Taqiyya is a
it's an Arabic word. It comes It's It's
derived from the Quran Quran 3:28.
Long story short, it's it's a doctrine
that tells Muslims you can dissemble
around the non-Muslim.
If and when you that non-Muslim is has
authority over you. So, if you're a
Muslim living in the UK and you're
outnumbered obviously by infidels, you
can dissemble your true intentions. And
as long as in your heart you're still a
Muslim trying to do the Muslim stuff and
you know, whatever whatever helps Islam
and fellow Muslims.
That's a broad umbrella term, but
there's all other there's a host of
other
technical
doctrines that also promote deception
against the infidel. Muhammad himself
said war is deceit on the one hand. On
the other hand, according to Islamic
doctrine, the non-Muslim the the Muslim
world is at perpetual war with the
non-Muslim world. They have an Arabic
term Dar al-Islam versus Dar al-Harb,
right? And so, until the Islamic world
subsumes one way or the other the
non-Islamic world, they're at war. Now,
even though it's perpetual and
existential, there can be truces when
the Muslims are weak. And so, whenever
they're weak, they can of course take
time It's not supposed to be suicidal.
It's not like you have to always declare
jihad even though your enemy is so much
more powerful. And that's sort of the
that's the phase we're in in general
with the Muslim world.
But
if if war is deceit
and
you know, you can play around and when
you're weak, you don't have to engage in
violence. Well, then you have a blank
blank check to engage in taqiyya 24/7.
And And of clerks have said that, okay?
Because where So when they come, let's
say here, well, you're the infidel.
There's another even deeper doctrine,
which I translate as loyalty and enmity,
in Arabic al-wala wal-bara, which is
Muslims have to stay clean of
non-Muslims, and even hate them. Okay?
And they have to help and ally with
Muslims. And they even say, even if the
non-Muslim is good to you, you have to
hate him.
And even if the fellow Muslim is not
good to you, you have to help work and
work with him. So it's like the ultimate
tribalism with a theological veneer.
And
that's very prominent, because that's
what prompts the jihad. Okay? If you're
the other, this is all ultimately,
remember, a tribal mentality. What
Muhammad did is he just deified the
tribal mores of 7th century Arabia,
which were such that
we're one tribe, and everyone outside of
the tribe is the enemy. They exist to be
killed, plundered, enslaved.
So now, he took that same thing, but now
it became not the other tribe. Well,
yeah, the other tribe of non-Muslims. So
everyone [clears throat] else is a part
of the other tribe. Therefore, we don't
befriend them. Um but unless you have
to. And then there's I mean, there's all
sorts of well-known clerks who say, you
know, smile to the face of the infidel,
but while your heart curses them. Um In
other words, you have to do what
whatever you have to do, as long as you
remain Muslim. And one primary example
happened during the Reconquista, where
the Christians essentially drove the
Muslims out of Spain. At the very, very
end, when they were holed up in one
final city, and the Christians said,
"Either convert or leave." They got a
fatwa saying precisely this. Taqiya. It
was okay, you can all you can go get
baptized, Catholic nation. You can you
know, partake of the communion, go to
their church, do everything, but remain
a Muslim. And this went on, there's
records
generation after generation. And there's
I always quote, there's a
a Spaniard who writes, and he says, he's
I think he was a priest. He says, "These
these people were better Christians than
us. They went to church more often. They
seemed more pious." And then they found
out at home they were Muslims preaching
hatred for the infidel. And this was
generation after generation.
So, that's how deep that can go. And I
often wonder, I can't imagine Western
Europe having the intelligence apparatus
to even begin to understand, you know,
that deep psychology and how it actually
impacts Muslim behavior. It's funny cuz
as you speak, I was thinking you've got
a certain Javier Bardem look. Mhm. And
he's a Spanish actor who is about as
woke as it we're wearing the the
Palestine stuff and all of that. But you
you've got a Has anyone ever told you
that before? No. That That particular
actor? Yeah. Yeah. He's a bit of a bit
of a Bardem but in a good way. He's a
He's a handsome man. Well, thank you.
>> [laughter]
>> But
the Spanish are about as bad as anyone
at this woke nonsense.
>> The Spanish spent 7 800 years, okay,
being terrorized and fighting to get
Muslims out of their country. And then
And then this this shows you again the
dangers of not knowing your history.
Yeah. And last I heard they just gave a
like a blanket check to 500,000 or a
million Africans that just came up and
they said, "Okay, hey, you can stay."
Shit. They just don't get it. It's just
amazing. This is This is
you know, the the classic example of
those who ignore history are destined to
repeat it.
But they I mean, this is something that
was taught in every school. That's the
funny thing. Spain's patron saint is
Saint James Matamoros. You know what
that means? Mhm. Saint James the Moor
slayer.
And there's all the images of him are on
a horse with a sword and then a bunch of
turbaned dark guys underneath being
stomped, okay?
>> going to allow that to be celebrated
anymore.
>> No. Well, of course not. But I mean, the
reason I tell you that is it shows you
that, you know, Spain was forged in that
environment of constant warfare with
Muslims. And now all of a sudden, oh
yeah, none of that matters. They were
just bigots. And oh, we're in a new age
of enlightenment. And you know, they
didn't know how to live and coexist, you
know? No, that's not it. Pep Guardiola,
the Manchester City manager, says that
he's the worst of them of all of that.
The stuff he comes out with. And he's
being paid huge sums by the Emirati, who
seem to actually be I mean, that that's
an interesting topic in and of itself,
isn't it? Because they don't seem to be
something to worry about, the Emirates
states,
as much as maybe the Pakistanis and so
on. What's your take on that?
Look, if if it's if it if it's a Muslim
a Muslim state if that person's a true
Muslim, and this goes back to the sort
of what you were saying, you know,
people coming for the good life and the
moderates.
It's just hard to tell because okay, his
name is Muhammad, and he comes from a
Muslim country, right? He may not know
or care about Islam or, you know, the
Quran, just like so many Jews and
Christians, right? You call them
Christians and Jews, but they're
secular. Yeah. So, you can, of course,
have that with a Muslim, and they're and
they come, you know, for the the good
life or whatever. But even those people,
you have to always remember, they still
have the cultural Islamic thing in their
mind. So, you don't have to be an ISIS
person who a radical is someone who
reads the Quran, and he literally tries
to implement the teachings of Sharia,
Hadith, and all that. The cultural
Muslim, though, you know, he may not
know any of this, but it's just part of
his upbringing.
And he doesn't even know where it comes
from, okay? So, so something like
deception, I'll be honest with you, that
is very much imbued culturally amongst
Muslim peoples. They probably don't even
know the word taqiyya, a lot of them.
They they don't know where it comes
from. But it's because it's so
normalized, then it becomes just it just
permeates the culture. Which is that
which begs the question cuz there's a
lot of people concerned that that
taqiyya aspect about So, so our party in
here
reform, they're the ones who are saying
we're going to stop immigration and so
on. And they're very much seen by some
on the left as the anti-Muslim party.
And yet it's it's it has people very
high up in it who are Muslim. Which I
think is often done. I mean, the same
reason that the Greens have got a gay
Jew in charge of them and
so we've got Z A Yousaf, we've got
Layla Cunningham who
seemed like brilliant speakers, really
smart. Can the British people and it it
seems unfair to even ask the question
cuz they're such nice, lovely people and
I've met them. Can the British people
trust those people?
Can they?
Um
I don't know. You can't trust any
people. I'll tell you it's like this.
Here's another analogy I'll give you,
okay? Let's let's let's give Muslims the
benefit of the doubt and you know, I
even even the most liberal sort of
estimates I hear will say something
like, you know, only 10% are radical.
Only 10% support the ISIS or whatever,
you know, Al-Qaeda view. Let's go with
that. I think it's bigger, the number,
but let's go with 10%. So, you know what
that's [snorts] like?
That's like I give you a a jar of
candies. There's a hundred.
And I know for a fact, cuz I've already
admitted 10% are radical, 10 of these
are poison. All right?
Now here, go give it to your kids. Would
you? No. Because you know, you know
that, yeah, most of them are going to be
good, but how do I tell which is the
good one? I can't. So, when you when you
give me an analogy or the example that
you said about this or that politician,
how can you tell? I mean, we already
know some are actively engaged in
taqiyya and lying and have are doing
what they want to do.
And we know that's a doctrine that's
been going on forever. So, how do I know
that particular Muslim is doing that?
And we also know some aren't. Some, you
know,
But of course, here's what I think. The
benefit of the doubt should not be uh or
or the burden of proof should not be put
on me.
You see what I'm saying? It's it's In
other words, it's it's really your
problem, Mr. Muslim, because you come
from this background and I know all this
stuff about Islam and you may be
innocent, but really the burden of proof
has to be on you, not me, because if
it's on me, I I have to take that risk
of the hundred candies and I don't want
to take a risk, even if it's one candy.
I'm not going to take that risk, okay?
And I'm sorry, but you're part of a
religion that makes it like that. So,
why do I have to be the one to take the
risk? Even Even if you are innocent, you
might be. I already said 90 out of 10,
maybe so maybe there's a 90% chance
you're innocent. But I don't And And
see, so that's what's happening actually
if you look at the politics today,
that is what the authorities are doing.
They'll tell you we know there's a
radical, but they're a minority, 10%.
So, okay, it's worth it. We're going to
bring them in and we're just going to
have occasional lash outs and Muslim
stabbing people and driving trucks and
blowing things up. Okay, it's worth it
for us, apparently. But if you said I
don't want any of that, okay, I really
care about my people, and
um you know, that's just the way it is,
and I'm sorry for all you good Muslims
who are out there,
um but that's just it's again the burden
of proof is on you. And you know how you
can prove it? Well, I guess leave Islam.
Even though that doesn't work because I
like we already said that that could be
a a ruse, yeah. It's something. Yeah.
Yeah. What What about the Jews, okay? A
lot of people on the far right I mean,
I'm a Jew myself, a secular one, but a
lot of people on the far right are
suggesting the Jews have helped to bring
this in. It's the great replacement
theory and and so on. Is And And this is
we're not the mainstream. If that's
true, then I want to know. Is there Is
there truth in some Jewish people doing
that? Honestly, I don't know, and I hear
this, but my take is always this. The
only good thing about the Western system
is it's technically transparent, which
means we know where the buck stops and
who makes the decisions, right? In the
UK it would be Starmer. Okay, is I don't
know, is he Jewish?
Okay, so he's the one that all the
pressure needs to be put on him because
he's making a decision. Now, whether
there's a secret cabal behind him who's
telling him to do this or not is really
kind of an irrelevant point. He's the
guy that was chosen. He's the guy that
makes the decisions. He's the guy that
has to be held accountable. Yeah. That's
the way I see it. I think that makes
more sense.
>> Yeah. Yeah. And the guys responsible for
the for the most immigration was the
Conservative Party. That was David
Cameron, Boris Johnson. Uh They're the
ones who are doing it. I don't I don't
you know if George Soros is floating
behind their back or whatever the case
may be, you're still the guy that's
doing it. But that's that's where the
accusation comes from, doesn't it? It's
Soros. It's There there is a contingent
of very left-wing Jews just as there are
right-wing and centrist Jews as well.
Yeah. Those guys do vote for left-wing
policies often.
But a lot of immigrants do, don't they?
They come to a country and then they all
start, which is I think is actually
that's a case it seems to be as well. A
lot of the left parties on the left seem
to be admitting almost and you know that
they're bringing in more and more
people to vote for Well, the the Spain
example, I'm pretty sure
you know, I told you they took in like
500 million. They literally some some
politician was a woman. I heard I saw a
video and she's boasting and she's
saying, "So you can replace the the
racist right you know, right-wing
voters."
Literally. They just admit it.
Fucking hell. It's it's it's so obvious
now as you know, the cat's out of the
bag as it were. Yeah, absolutely. What
about
things
Have you seen King Charles?
He's it's actually gone nuts the last
year. I mean, do you do you follow I
mean you know you're in the States.
>> whole lot, but I mean I'm familiar with
it, yeah. It's the football stadiums
firstly, that's one of the biggest
cultural institutions and stadium after
stadium that the the football teams on
Twitter, the soccer soccer teams for
Americans uh
are having prayers being held, Islamic
prayers in in the stadia.
Um we've got King Charles constantly
holding in the palace Muslim prayers and
things like that. Are we further gone
than people even realize?
Yeah, I actually spoke with someone
recently about um King Charles and he
made an interesting point. He said,
"Well, he does that because he's you
know, it goes back to sort of the
colonial era and he feels like he's the
king of all the people, subject peoples,
many of who are Muslims. So he has to
represent them too." Um
okay, so you know, okay, I suppose that
makes a little bit of sense, but having
said that, I just don't think that any
na- any nation, any culture, any
civilization, let's say Britain
should in any way, shape or form
you know, moderate, water down, or uh uh
suppress its culture to accommodate
anyone.
>> Mhm. And the reason for that is nobody
does that. Muslims don't do that. Hindus
don't do that. Buddhists don't do that,
okay? Who Who does that? Japanese don't
do it. Nobody do that. And they
shouldn't because this is our land, this
is our law, this is our culture. You
assimilate.
So, when I see that sort of thing, which
I'm seeing with both with Charles and
just everyone else, you know, all the
politicians and the overall uh
I heard, for example, last Christmas, um
they try a lot of some countries would
especially that have large Muslim
populations would make, you know, the
images, the traditional images kind of
they'd make them more bland so you don't
even know what you're looking at. Like
Like let's say manger scene, Mary and
it would just be like three heads and
you don't even know what that is. Mhm.
Um so, that's that's a perfect example
of actually just capitulating.
And in so doing, radicalizing Muslims
even more, emboldening them because
you're showing them, yeah, these people
they're weak. Let's take over.
>> I think there's a bit of victimhood as
well. That victimhood kind of grows uh
the more you're given. It's the same
thing as what you're saying, the
entitled feeling. But if you're you have
years and years where uh they won't show
the manger scene or or they won't they
don't say happy Christmas, Merry
Christmas. Then when someone does say
Merry Christmas, each individual Muslim
probably does feel like, hey, Yeah. okay
you guys, you we'd agreed that was
>> Yeah, exactly. Well, that's what happens
cuz you've accustomed them to being a
panzy. So, how dare you How dare you
now, you know, try to We've already
agreed we don't want to see these things
and you gave in. Yeah. Shit. Do you
[laughter] think there are How deep does
this go in terms of elites, in terms of
globalists, Davos, these that kind of
class of people getting embedded with
the Muslim Brotherhood, say?
I [snorts] think there's there's, you
know, levels to it, you know, the
highest echelons. I think it's that sort
of thing, the globalists um who who very
consciously know what they're doing, you
know, the the Soros mentality, okay?
That's that's there. But then the rank
and file are just, you know, your
average person uh including a lot of
these politicians, they're just, you
know, they're they're so part of the
matrix, they can't even think or realize
what they're doing is wrong or bad
because they've they've been drinking
the Kool-Aid more than anyone. So, they
really believe in this stuff. They're
the ultimate useful idiots and they're
more of the masses. And then the real
masses, of course, would be any, you
know, the typical left woke person who's
not even a politician, but he's
brainwashed by by, I don't know, social
media or whatever. Um so, I think it
kind of it is a little little bit
top-down in that sense.
Um but yeah, I I
I also think there has to be some, you
know, the top echelon has to be
conscious of what it's doing. And
whatever that agenda is, globalization,
um
I I recall
what was his name?
The famous uh UK politician. Enoch
Powell or someone. During Bush's era.
Uh rather than Blair
>> Blair, Blair, Blair, yeah. Like
apparently back then he said something
like that. Like, yeah, my goal is to
make sure that Britain becomes global.
He said something like to stick one in
the eye of every
I need to figure I'm going to look that
up but when your next song I'll have a
look at what that was. The Kool-Aid
thing about drinking the Kool-Aid, yeah,
that was Flavor-Aid and but they've got
changed to Kool-Aid. It was Flavor-Aid
and it was um
>> Oh, was it? It was the Jonestown
tragedy. Do you know? And they he took
them to um he was a
nutter in charge of the cult
uh and he took them, Jim Jones, to uh
some South American place and set them
all up there and then they all drank
Flavor-Aid with probably cyanide or some
sort of poison and they all died. But it
just shows what an ideology can do. That
is the perfect example of it, I think.
God, um and then I'm I'm going to look
that up in a second about what Blair
actually said cuz you're right, which is
Yeah. fascinating.
>> way back then, you know, so his his uh
Well, there was you mentioned 9/11 at
the beginning. Um it it's it's really
like
it that was sort of a moment where we
could have gone one of like two ways and
the reaction after that was all the
Hollywood guys coming out and just and
and even Bush saying Muslim Islam is a
religion of peace. It's extra Is that's
why I want to get onto this like elite
side of it. I mean, I was told recently
the Muslim Brotherhood is 50 years into
a 100 year plan. It was Charles Asher
Small was telling me about that. Have
you Have you
looked into that? I don't know
particularly about 50 100 year, but I I
I do know they definitely work very
incrementally. Mhm. Uh I think in 2000 I
want to say nine
uh the FBI busted all these Muslim
Brotherhood documents which
including famous organizations like CAIR
in the US
and they literally said that we are
engaged in a civilizational jihad
against America in this case and and and
we're going to do X, Y, and Z. We're
going to use their own system against
them until we sabotage their miserable
house. These are verbatim quotes. Huh.
The civilizational jihad, the sabotage,
the miserable house.
So it's
and that's how these things always are.
They're very long term, very
incremental, very subtle. You have to do
it incrementally. That's how people get
used to it, right? You you introduce
something very subtle in the beginning
and then
give it a few years and people accept
it. That's the new norm and then you go
a little further. Um so that that
definitely is an agenda of the
Brotherhood and all sorts of Islamist.
That's what makes the the Brotherhood
type more dangerous than the ISIS type.
The ISIS type, you know what you're
dealing with. Just you know, pure savage
savage carnage.
>> Yeah. Uh but the Muslim Brotherhood type
is the is the sort that you know, they
they use the West's own infrastructure
and system against it. And like I said,
do it subtly and incrementally. That cuz
that was remarkable that you had the
president right after the biggest
terrorist attack ever coming out and
saying it is a religion of peace.
Yeah. Yeah. And this is back in 2001
before wokery, you know. Yeah. We had
even you know, 15 years ago we had in
the UK there were documentaries on the
BBC about the Islamic infiltration of
the UK and what was really happening the
radicalization of the mosques.
We had people looking at certain towns
and going back to their hometown and
saying shit what's going on here? This
is crazy and then silence. Like it got
to that point it's like it passed that
point and now there's no more. Does the
average American do they just have no
idea what's about to hit them?
>> [snorts]
>> Yeah, probably the average American
unfortunately just you know
there I I imagine like the average
Westerner is just their noses on their
phone social media and the worst part is
then some of them are watching Fox News
or whatever CNN and they think they're
informed and I don't know
I don't know if you're informed or
indoctrinated. Mhm. [clears throat]
Okay, so a lot of it seems to me the
people who think they're informed are
the least informed because they it's
kind of like same phenomena of what's
going on with public school systems. You
go there and you think you're the
educated one but you've actually your
head's been filled with all sorts of
nonsense including woke nonsense
nowadays.
So
I think by and large I obviously a lot
it's hard to say but a lot of people I
think viscerally understand something's
wrong here too. But they can't put their
finger on it and I think one of the
reasons for this is like I said we keep
looking at symptoms not root causes and
the symptoms so Islam is a symptom Islam
in the West is a symptom it's not the
root cause. And the root causes as all
root causes are ultimately more
philosophical and that's why they're
harder to kind of pinpoint and
understand and usually they've taken
generations to actually mature and
permeate society but in this particular
case for example
that's why I say okay let's say the West
UK okay could tomorrow take care of the
Islam problem.
They could physically they have the
capacity to do it and they have the
authority to do it all right but the
mentality has so changed. In other words
if I if if all the you the native Brits
living here, okay, the white native
Brits were replaced by their
great-grandparents, okay, including the
government, the Islam problem would be
solved in a few days,
>> [laughter]
>> okay? And what would they have to do?
What would be done? It would even if it
would be something like, "Hey, you know
what? We don't want to live with you
people in the way you are. We're going
to pay it. We're going to send you
straight back to your countries. We're
going to have give you an allowance,
some money,
but that's just the way it is."
What are you going to do about it? Okay,
but now the philosophical underpinnings
of their descendants is such that I can
never even conceive of doing that
because I'm a humanist, because that
might traumatize someone, because okay,
see all these sorts of things that have
crept into the Western epistemology have
paralyzed people. Okay, so it's not that
it can't be done. It can be done. Lots
of things can be done, you know, the UK
can be
go back to being merry old England if it
wants in any time, okay? But
it be due to these really
you know, paralyzing philosophies that
have just permeated the culture so much
and the epistemology, people can't act.
All they can do is talk about this new
party, this new politician, I'm going to
vote and
but if you zoom out and look at what's
happening, it's just been a complete
downhill spiral.
It doesn't It doesn't matter, you know.
The ideology behind
multiculturalism, individualism,
the liberty that we've had in the 1900s
and the early 2000s in the UK and the US
and Europe, it's really strong and it's
really attractive so that even I I've
been doing this show called Heretics
which is, you know, against a lot of the
the mainstream and so on. Even I've
bulked at the idea of oh, but but
sending people back who are individuals
who live here. And it's I'm only getting
to the point now. It's taken years of
speaking to people like you every other
day for 2 and 1/2 years to to even get
to a point where I'm going, "Oh, shit,
maybe we've got no choice." And so,
you'd have to sit like Clockwork Orange.
You'd have to sit the average person
down, hold their eyes open for 2 years.
That's how you get people out of cults.
It's slow.
>> Yeah, I know. I know. Uh But there isn't
much time for that. That's the problem.
>> to happen. It's not going to happen.
Shit, man. I I don't know. And then they
would say, a lot of those people would
say, as a Scientologist would say, of
anyone who's disagreeing with them,
they're a suppressive person. Those are
the words they use. They go, "Don't
listen to them." basically. They would
say that we've been that you and I are
radicalized. Yeah. And we're black
pilling. Yeah. Yeah. How do we How do we
make them realize we're not we're not Or
maybe we are.
Uh I'm not radicalized. I'm just normal.
That's what everyone says, though.
That's like people saying, "I don't have
an accent." I'm I'm just all I'm Well, I
I see your point, but what I'm saying is
I'm just telling you how things work
historically and how things can work
today.
If you want something done, look, if
you're going to define your culture and
your policies by the way they are
defined, which is, you know, the human
rights and and of course I'm not
attacking human rights, but they've also
been weaponized. You have to understand.
All these terms, multiculturalism, you
know, what What's so great about multi
When you think about it, do you know
what a culture is? They seem to think
that cultures are exotic food. Mhm. No,
actually a culture is a distinct world
view. So, how is it great when you get a
society where everyone has a different
world view, different priorities,
different ethics, and you throw them in
together? That's good? I think I'd
prefer homogeneity.
You know what I mean?
That's how a country should be. Now,
it's it's one thing to say different
races. I'm I'm I'm I've no problem with
that, as long as they all share the
same, you know, the the same priorities
and the same culture. Okay, that can
work. But to bring in and celebrate the
fact that everyone believes in something
differently, okay, so even in and of
itself, that's insane. Why would any
country want that? And we celebrate
that? It makes no sense. Yeah. So,
people don't They They They just They
don't get it. They've been duped. Um
It's a beautiful word, as well. It's a
beautiful word. It's been made
beautiful, okay? And I like I said, most
people think it means
instead of walking out of my bland
British house and just seeing a bunch of
white people all stuffy, I'm going to
see exotic Indians and I'm going to see
a turbaned man and I'm going to go get
really authentic food and wow, that's
awesome. That's multiculturalism. Well,
no, actually the real thing about
multiculturalism is all those people
have a different world view than you.
Completely different.
>> each other.
>> Yeah. There's a reason I said this to
someone recently. I said, "Would you go
and live in Pakistan?" And he he said
no. We were having an argument and he
said no and I said, "Why not?" He said,
"Well, I I don't know actually. Well,
maybe I would. I haven't I
I was like, "No, you wouldn't." He said,
"No, cuz I haven't been there." And I
said, "There's a reason you haven't
fucking been there."
>> Is he Pakistani? No. But he cuz he was
just like he was fine with the influx of
Pakistanis.
So, I said, "Would you live there?" Cuz
that's what we're bringing here. And he
started by saying like, "No, I
wouldn't." And then he's continued by
saying, "Well, I haven't been there
actually, so Maybe he would. So, he's
lying. Straight to his face. Yeah, maybe
I would live there in Pakistan. It's
like I I know so many people who were
quite woke or multicultural who've gone
on holiday to India with their
girlfriends or wives and walked down the
street and had the most appalling That
is That is what that has to happen, I
think, with the 50 60 million Brits
every and Americans. They all have to go
on holiday with their blonde wives and
walk down the street in India. In in you
know, not in every city. Well, or or
just here in London, right? Yeah, well,
that's it. It's not It's a joke. What
What's What is going on? Tell me a
little bit and and
relatively briefly. But but what's
what's what's happened in Iran? What's
So So there was a Shah, then there's
this What's going on?
Yeah, as far as the you know, the
minute-to-minute thing, I don't think
anyone knows. There seems to be kind of
a clampdown, which makes sense. During
war, you don't want to actually say
what's going on.
>> [snorts]
>> But um
the Shah, of course, is the original guy
who's who was secular um and it's his
son that I think the US is supporting
and trying to supplant and bring him in.
Yeah. And Iran's, you know, the history
of Iran and its actual, you know, who it
is is it's so different than most of the
Muslim world. It's very, very different.
So, first of all, it's it's the only
nation who got conquered very early, but
it kept its language, which is very
bizarre, okay?
All the other countries, my people, the
Copts of Egypt, they had their own
language. It's the the Coptic language,
it's the Pharaonic language. It exists
only in the liturgy in church, you know,
it's not a spoken language anymore.
That's why we call 22 or 23 countries
Arab countries because their first
language is Arabic. You know, Coptic
came from the ancient Egyptian language.
Yeah, yeah. It's the final form of the
ancient Yeah, so
>> use hieroglyphics in it still as
>> No, we use a Greek alphabet
and seven different characters that
don't exist, but it's the same words,
you know, so it's spelled with Greek
alphabet. Wow. But yeah, so if you hear
a Coptic liturgy, that's how the
pharaohs would have sounded. That's
amazing.
>> It is kind of cool. Yeah, I like that.
And so it so Iran is different. What do
they It's not Persian, is it? What's the
Yeah, Persian, Farsi. Farsi. Um, that's
what they speak and it
and also they kept their culture. And
then when they, you know, they become
Shia Muslims, which is you know, the the
heretical Muslim form, you know, most
most of them are Sunni, so they're the
outcasts, which is the minority, 10%.
And they have a kind of a different
theology, so they have this hidden Imam,
okay? Imam, you may know the word from
Sunnis like a prayer leader. Their Imam
means like the great leader who's sort
of almost like an immaculate He's a
descendant of Muhammad ultimately.
Right. You know, through his his
daughter uh Fatima and and Ali.
And uh
Iran's a twelver Shia.
They have numbers, there's fiver, seven.
Twelver means um, you know, the the 12th
Imam is the one that disappeared and
he's still alive. Mhm. I think he
disappeared around 8 or 900. And he's
going to come back, okay? So, very, very
mystical, esoteric. And the Ayatollah,
you know, Ayatollah means like
like the
the miracle of Allah, okay? It's A is
the same word for verse, which is like a
Anyway, he's like his representative.
Now, the issue what's interesting about
all this is the eschatological component
of Shia Islam is gives cause to pause,
especially when we talk about nuclear
weapons.
Because their end days deal with this
Mahdi figure. Mahdi's means the guided
one and also
he's going to help bring the the hidden
Imam, okay? But to do that, there has to
be a cataclysmic showdown with the
enemies of Islam, in this case Shia
Islam, which are named we know them, the
two great Satans, all right? Israel and
America.
So, that's why when you think of nuclear
powers, you usually [clears throat]
think of the balance of powers, you
know, it's a deterrent. You have it, I
have it. No one's going to use it.
Um the mentality of this group, Iran's a
little more risqué because they might
use something like that to usher in the
day they've all been waiting for, which
is when the great Imam returns.
Um and this isn't just my theory, a lot
of scholarly papers have been written
about that particular aspect to that.
And it really permeates, especially the
Islamic Republican Guard Corps, which is
in in charge of Iran.
And you know, honestly, the taking out
of the Ayatollah, I don't know how good
that was. I think they were counting on
a decapitation strike, which to my
knowledge has never worked.
But they've made a martyr of him and and
it's very anything, it seems, again,
depending on who I who you talk to, but
it seems like it may be galvanizing a
significant portion of the Iranian
people. So, so it's a weird country
because you've got this country, as you
said, that doesn't have Arabic. It
hasn't So, it seems like it's almost
more secular at the first glance.
>> Well,
that's the thing. The people are
supposedly very secular, but they're
governed by this mullah autocracy, you
know, the theocracy.
But there's also, you know, a sort of
relationship, you know, he's he's like
this nice grandfatherly figure and they
we we respect him and that's why it
wasn't I don't think smart to kill him.
Uh. What what what authority did he
have? He was like an 80-plus year old
man. It's not like uh he was the one
making all the decisions.
So, I don't know how smart that was. If
anything, that might have like pushed
even the secular the Iranians to be more
supportive. Kind of like, "Look at these
people. They're treacherous. They killed
this old man."
So, I don't know. Not the I don't know
if that was really a good move um to
help overall. Uh but but again, I think
they were just banking on it the whole
thing's going to collapse if we kill
him.
I think they have to kill maybe the
whole um you know, IRC the IRG, the
Islamic Republican Guard, before that
happens.
>> I suppose no one knows the exact
numbers, but it feels like there's this
real secular group of Iranians or
Iranians that I've met loads of them in
England. And they're always great
people.
>> Yeah. Just these great people. They are.
And then there's like super extreme
Muslims. But it's like those two are
there.
>> Yeah. And then so how big is the super
extreme
>> That's the question, right? And it
depends on who you talk to. Some people
tell me, "Oh, it's 95% they're secular.
Cool." And then I'll meet someone else
who's like, "No, no, it's like it's more
like 60% are kind of it's not that
they're radical, but they're
conservative, which means they do back
the regime for heritage reasons, for
pride, for honor. We're not going to you
know, who are these infidels to come and
kill this old man, you know, who Maybe
we don't like him, but he represents us,
you know, it's it's that honor culture.
Okay? Yeah.
Is there any chance you think that
they they get overthrown, maybe the Shah
comes back in or
>> Sure. Yeah, yeah. I mean, at this That's
what I mean. I don't know what's going
on. Uh but that definitely is a uh
plausible possibility. Or not even
necessarily the Shah. It could be just
someone else who is, you know,
>> Basically elected. politically elected
and ideally, you know, pro uh US,
pro-Western, pro-Israel.
That's unlikely though, isn't it?
I mean, are there examples I think you
mentioned Spain before of you know, this
kind of
when Islam gets embedded in with the
elite establishment where they've then
been pushed back out and a country that
a culture has been regained.
Are there other examples aside from that
Spanish
>> other examples? Oh, you're talking about
like where let's say a conquered people
pushed out Islam? Yeah. Oh, there's
plenty. Um
Uh
you have to remember that if you look at
the 7th century when Islam starts
spreading through Jihad essentially, if
you want to talk about let's just talk
about the Christian world or Christendom
which people thought was Europe. It was.
It was actually not even all of Europe.
It was southwest of the Danube and
Rhine. But it was mostly North Africa
and mostly the Middle East. What we call
So I'll think of all those Middle
Eastern countries, Syria, Israel,
Lebanon, Jordan, um Egypt, Syria of
course, Egypt, Libya, all the way to
Morocco.
And Asia Minor, Turkey. All of that was
Christian. More Christian. That's why
Constantine, the Roman emperor, moved
his capital to the East because that's
where all was.
Now all of that was conquered in one
century.
Okay, by Islam. And that's why it's kind
of funny because people seem to think
that that area was always somehow kind
of like Muslim or Yeah. turban-wearing
people. Well, actually it was That was a
more sophisticated, richer, and even
theologically advanced portion of the
Christian world. You had five major
centers known as seas. One was in Rome.
The other four, which were just as
equal, were all absorbed and conquered
by Islam. Antioch, Alexandria,
Jerusalem, and later Constantinople. So
think about that. Now as far as
those So who did actually The ones that
we So the Muslim world as we know it,
MENA, Middle East, North Africa,
obviously those people were not able to
get rid of Islam. But there were
uprisings, believe it or not, here and
there.
But
people forget Southeast Europe, the
Balkans, were conquered by Islam. Um you
know, the under the Ottomans. they came
all the way up to
Vienna.
Hungary was conquered. That's why
Hungary says, "We don't want Muslims. We
know what it's like to live with Muslims
because we were conquered for 150
years." But a lot of the other Balkan
nations were, too. Russia, you know, you
may have heard of the of the Tatar or
the Mongol yoke. Well, they became
Muslim. And the same sort of it was the
same paradigm immediately
engulfed Russia where, you know, the the
Muslim master, you're the infidel, you
know, you have to pay the tribute and
live this is so the whole thing there.
So,
and they but all those countries did
manage to push Islam out. Russia and the
the Balkans and Hungary. And but that
was much later than Spain because they
they got conquered later and, you know,
basically, let's say Hungary got freed
of Islam completely and totally in the
1700s, okay?
Greece was under the Ottoman yoke. We
know what the Ottomans did to the
Armenians and the Assyrians and the
Greeks, okay? It's just difficult cuz
all of those countries they were live
they were in a time where they didn't
have this kind of multiculturalism and
this human rights era.
>> Right. Yeah. They were more normal and
down-to-earth and they knew what it was.
>> We would have we would have to act in a
way that is not not we just won't do
that.
>> Yeah. Okay. Who
>> [laughter]
>> I've got one more question for you, but
where where can people find your work
and all of that? Yeah, thanks. Um, well,
I have a Substack which I think is in my
name Substack page and also my books you
can find them on my website
raymondibrahim.com
or on Amazon.
My newest book just came out Two Swords
of Christ which actually deals with a
lot of these themes and a lot of people
are liking it. And
yeah, my YouTube channel. Oh, yeah, of
course. We'll we'll link to all of that.
I hope you will do go and check it out
because it's so important that people I
mean, if if nothing else, be informed.
Like that that's essential. So, they
need to be informed. So, I hope people
go and check all of that out.
Who is a heretic you admire?
A heretic [snorts] I admire. Hmm.
That's a good question. Hmm. Oh, I know.
Vlad the Impaler.
Go on. Well, Vlad the Impaler as we know
him, Dracula, is of course a demonized
figure
by all means a heretic of course. Most
Christians would literally call him a
heretic.
But in the real history that I delve
into and talk about, I have a whole
chapter about him actually in one of my
books, Defenders of the West, the
Christian heroes who stood against
Islam. I look at the primary sources and
what I see is yeah, he engaged in
violence and brutality, but so did
everyone else. And he was really
weakened and outnumbered so he engaged
in a little bit more to make a point.
But if you look at who he was, he what
he identified himself as a Christian,
Orthodox in this case, and he was
fighting to defend his people from the
Muslims, the Ottoman Turks who were
coming and demanding boys to become
Janissaries. That's what they would do.
They would take Christian boys and force
them to become Janissaries. Why? Yeah,
and enslavement and all that. So he got
very brutal
in order to fight that back and it's in
in Romania, his homeland and also in a
lot of Eastern Europe he's he's seen as
a hero. But here in the West, you know,
heretic is just begins to touch on who
he is. He's actually a blood sucking
demon that you know sleeps by day and
I mean and sleeps in a coffin by day,
which he wasn't. [laughter] That's a
great heresy. That's the first time he's
been mentioned as a as a heretic. I like
that.
Bring back the
fire. Bring back the
>> [music]
>> flame. Bring back the
fire
and the righteous